جانبه قال المتحدث باسم الجيش الاسرائيلي
دانييل ها جاري ان الجيش الاسرائيلي يقاتل
في مناطق وصفها بالمعقد في خانيونس اضاف
ها جاري انه نتيجه لعمليات تدمير الانفاق
خرج العديد من المسلحين من تحت الارض
واطلقوا النار على القوات
[موسيقى]
الاسرائيليه نقاتل في مناطق قتال معقده
ومنطقه كخان يونس هي ايضا منطقه ذات كثافه
سكانيه عاليه كما نحدد مواقع البنيه
الاساسيه الارهابيه وخاصه تحت الارض وفي
خان يونس وسعنا فرقه القوات الهندسيه هناك
هذه الفرقه لديها عدد قوات اكبر من العدد
المعتاد وهذا ما يتطلبه الوضع وسنقوم ايضا
بتوسيع قدراتها في الايام المقبله وقد
سمحت العمليه البريه بتدمير شامل للاسلحه
والبنيه الاساسيه تحت الض حتى الان دمرت
قواتنا وصدرت نحو 30 الف عبوه كانت في
ايدي
حماس